t.i and wife tamika tiny harris are
under police investigation
in los angeles following claims of
sexual assault and drugging
the lapd confirmed to e.t that there is
an active investigation but declined to
provide more
information at this time et has reached
out to ti
and tiny's reps for comment in march
attorney tyrone blackburn who is
representing multiple women
announced that he was seeking criminal
charges against the couple
blackburn said he's representing 11
accusers
including 10 women and one man who
claimed to be victims
of numerous crimes including kidnapping
drugging and sexual assault allegedly
committed by t.i
and tiny the couple's attorney released
a statement to e.t in march
denying the allegations saying we are
confident that if these claims are
thoroughly
and fairly investigated no charges will
be forthcoming
the harrises implore everyone not to be
taken in by these obvious attempts to
manipulate the press
and misuse the justice system in a
letter to the california state attorney
general
blackburn claimed that his firm has been
contacted by
over 30 women in the past two weeks with
additional allegations claiming that the
couple aided by
several individuals in their employ have
kidnapped them
drugged them raped them and terrorized
them with threats of death or physical
bodily harm
he added the alleged incidents occurred
in los angeles as well as georgia and
florida between
2005 and 2018. the attorney claimed that
all 11 clients
recount eerily similar events of sexual
abuse
force ingestion of illegal narcotics
kidnapping
terroristic threats and false
imprisonment
production on the fourth season of the
couple's reality show t.i and tiny the
family hustle was put on hold in early
february
when allegations against the pair began
to surface on social media
tim and i have had our ups and downs but
we're finally in a great place together
it gives us time to focus on the kids
and help them grow in april 2020 et
spoke with tiny about how her marriage
is going to be played out
on tv i think you know this season for
us as far as a relationship as far as i
can remember
in the season everything was really
pretty good you know what i'm saying was
probably
some of our best times and you know even
when i um
our film crew they was like wow like
this has been
amazing you guys haven't been fussing
and you know we've been like really on
one accord
and very loving and trying to work with
each other i'm not saying we don't have
spats here and there you know but of
course we it's been like a real
close-knit fun like uh like we
back in love like old time when we first
got together
so you know that is you know really good
because we've been able to find
ourselves back into that
to that place and i think that's a a
very hard thing to do it's like
fresh new love you know